Bonsoir !
Bonjour à tous!
Vous n'êtes pas sur la chaîne de McFly et Carlito.
Mais c'est les cinq ans de Golden donc on est contents !
Ouais !
Tout le monde n'est pas là mais on a réunit un petit panel de gens
pour regarder des vidéos
et donner des anecdotes à la fois croustillantes, tendres et drôles.
Ouais !
Mais également une big up à tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir
A savoir : Eléonore Costes, Justine Le Pottier, Aude Gogny-Goubert, McFly et Carlito,
Akim Omiri,
Continuez parce que...
Les Suricates !
Les Suricates ! Akim Omiri !
Je l'ai dis je crois !
Les Suricates !
Est-ce qu'on est prêts ?
On est prêts à y aller ?
Ouais !
Premier sketch !!!!!
Oui c'est à quel sujet ?
Marc Jean rousseau.
Qui fait la voix ?
Alors la voix c'est Adrien Ménielle.
Le corps c'est moi.
C'est incroyable.
J'ai la gestuelle d'Adrien Menielle.
C'est dingue, parce qu'en vrai si quelqu'un a deviné ça, c'est ouf !
J'ai la meilleur coupe de ma vie.
Cette coupe est incroyable mec !
Mais ça c'est ta coupe par contre.
C'est pas une perruque en fait !
Rien que les costumes ils sont dingues.
Alors c'est grace au travail énorme de Charlotte qui est à la production de Golden Moustache
qui à passé trois semaines à ne pas dormir,
à contacter des gens qui font des costumes, des Cosplayers, des passionnés...
D2 c'est un mec qui s'appelle Eric,
Qui à fabriqué lui même son R2 et ça fait 6 ans qu'il est dessus.
Et il continue à l'améliorer et c'est ouf.
En revanche, il s'appelait Léo, il était extrêmement mignon,
il nous fait chialer de mignonnerie.
Et Big Up aussi à Antoine Beheagel
qui à fait tout les FX, tout les habillages, tout le graphisme.
Les trucs qui tournent, animés.
Antoine Beheagel ?
Il a un nom de traître
mais c'est vraiment un mec très cool !
Et vous entendez la petite voix de Carlito à la toute fin.
Oui j'ai pris quelques libertés, oui.
C'est Carlito.
Ah ouais ?
Qui a réalisé le sketch, oui c'est lui.
Peut-être pourrait-il être mit sur d'autre Saga, qu'en penses tu ?
Ouais et bien c'est possible.
Vas-y chante le générique de la prochaine saga qui sera dans le "Bureau des plaintes".
Le seigneur des anneaux.
L'histoire en fait des "Entre vous émoi",
c'est que il y à longtemps j'étais dans une radio suisse
J'avais une chronique vidéo avec Blaise Bersinger.
En fait on faisaient des interviews un peu décalées comme ça,
Et je suis content parce que c'est une série
qui à bien marchée...
Que tu continues !
Que je continue sur ma chaîne et j'ai sorti cinq épisodes sur Golden.
Abonnez-vous !
Voilà y a une anecdote aussi
C'est que deux épisodes, c'est pas Bachet qu'est là, c'est McFly !
En fait la vrai histoire c'est que Bachet avait un petit souci aux testicules.
Je sais pas si on peut le dire ?
On est là pour dire la vérité.
Il avait un peu mal...
Et il est allé voir le médecin, bon c'était rien finalement.
Ce que j'aime bien c'est que tu le dis dabord,
et après tu dis "J e sais pas si on peut le dire".
Personne ne le remarque, mais...
Mais t'as une perruque !
Ça c'est du Yop !
Essai de la refaire.
C'était du Yop à la fraise.
C'est très drôle à un moment tu chies sur un chauve.
Succès assurée
David Bowie !
Ça c'était avant que tu viennes ?
Ouais ça c'était avant...
"Entre vous émoi" le titre à été trouvé par Adrien Ménielle.
Qui était directeur artistique à l'époque.
Ouais, je suis très content de faire cette série, de pouvoir la continuer.
Du coup on fait quoi, pause déj ?
Pause déj? Ben ouais ouais !
Et ça commence avec de la baise !
Et aller !
Ce qui m'a soulé c'est qu'à la base je voulais la faire cette scène !
Avec moi ?
Ben oui !
D'ou vient cette petite idée de sketch de capote là ?
Ben euh...
Je pense que comme beaucoup de personne, on a vécu cette situation
où on est avec une fille et personne n'a de capote.
J'ai vraiment rencontré des mecs, un petit groupe de cailleras
Et y a vraiment quelqu'un qui m'a dit
Ben au pire tu me fais une éjac..
Faciale !
Faciale.
Ça c'est vrai.
Ç a c'est vrai ça.
C'était très très drôle ne plus, on tournaient de nuit.
Ça c'est pas drôle
Ce qui était drôle c'est que y avait des gars, on filmait de nuit, c'était un vendredi soir.
qui venaient faire la fête.
On a vraiment tourné toute la nuit.
On tournaient près d'une porte, et ils étaient complètement arrachés,
Je pense qu'ils avaient pris de la drogue.
Et ils se mettaient derrière nous, et ils faisaient
J'men bats les couilles, on s'met derrière eux, on va peut-être rentrer avec eux.
Ce qui est drôle, c'est que on a mit un couteau "Sabatier"
parce que le réalisateur s'apelle Florent Sabatier.
Et ça nous faisaient rigoler.
C'est très drôle.
C'est bien marrant.
Là aussi, Eddy...
Il est chanmé quoi !
Et tu lui as mis une golden là ?
Ah yes !
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est tourné dans un quartier de Paris
où la nuit il y a beaucoup d'activité.
C'était un vendredi soir.
Ça picole beaucoup et c'est vraiment une rue de la soif.
Et la c'est petite course, regardez moi cette petite course !
Ça c'est une capote...
Amaury et Quentin
Tout simplement !
Qui on été faites, exprès pour le sketch.
D'ailleurs on va les essayer.
Anis !
On a pensé à toi pour être cobaye.
C'est parti !
Voilà !
On coupe pas !
On coupe surtout pas !
Ce qu'on peut dire aussi, c'est que y a du contenu
Que vous faites pour Golden youtube,
Y a du contenu qui est sur votre chaîne et qui n'est pas forcément sur youtube.
Et c'est vrai ou pas ?
Je vais la mettre sur la tête de ma mère !
Non mais la met pas sur la tête de ta mère, met la sur ta bite !
Allez, yes !
Alors ça c'est "Pervenche" !
Ça viens d'un truc que je vais balancer,
J'imaginais juste des agents ASVP.
Badass, parce ils le sont pas du tout dans la vie
Batard !
Qui la mise en scène ? Carlito !
Carlito du duo, McFly et Carlito !
Exactement !
On fait pas confiance à grand monde et on lui a fait confiance et on le regrette pas.
Je me permets, n'ayant rien fais sur ce sketch, de vous féliciter parce que j'adore ce sketch.
Ah c'est gentil !
Et c'était une super journée d'être habillé comme ça !
On faisaient chier les gens.
On allaient voir les gens et on faisait "Ben alors".
"Ben alors on est mal garé ?"
Et les gens ils croyaient qu'on étaient vraiment Pervenche, alors que non !
Les gens ont cru vraiment que Freddy prenait en otage des gens ?
Ben il s'est pris une balle...
Là je hurlais dans l'oreille de Justine qui vraiment...
a pris cher !
Justine, je suis désolé !
C'est ça que vous cherchez hein ?
Là elle souffre !
A un moment elle a pas mit un bout de mouchoir ?
On dirait que tu braques ses cheveux !
Uniquement ça en fait.
Ben c'est ce à quoi elle tient le plus !
Regardez Anis le ninja...
Polala !
Ce lancé !
Tout est dans la langue !
Tout ces comédiens, c'est très fort.
Et là on voulait qu'il y ai un mec qui dise : Calzone ?
Vous allez voir le saut d'Anis qui est très particulier.
Les deux sont pas oufs.
Moi j'ai découvert après ça, car je suis arrivé l'après midi,
Et donc j'ai découvert dans les rushes ces sauts, vous allez voir, regardez.
Je t'emmerde.
C'est très académique, attention !
Ah Guili Guili !
Réalisé par le très bon Tom Evrard.
Ce qui est marrant c'est que "N'importe quoi sérieux",
ils l'ont mit là parce qu'on voit pas mes lèvres.
On peut mettre ce qu'on veut.
Par exemple, dis un truc !
Bonsoir !
Etiez vous à l'aise ?
A l'aise de comédien.
Parce que vous êtes de vrais comédiens.
T'es gêné, elle lâche une caisse et après t'es bien.
Là il se rend compte que ses mains...
Y a une scène très Spider-Manesque.
Ah tu crois que t'as un pouvoir ? Ah putain, mais j'avais pas compris en fait !
Il est fort !
Bon bien sur c'est un sketch qui a été fait avant l'affaire Weinstein.
Ah la Bernificotine !
Alors qu'est qu'il nous dit Berno ?
Ben j'ai 54 ans.
Et là je le porte clairement en fait !
C'est dur en fait !
C'est un peu lourd !
Est-ce que ce regard cam serait pas improvisé ?
Dédicace à Clément Marouze pour avoir gardé ce petit regard cam.
Dédicace aussi à tout les figurants qui viennent sur les tournages !
Ouais !
Là c'est la première fois qu'on jouent ! Qu'on jouent à trois !
C'est la première fois de Multiprise.
Olàlà !
Qu'est-ce que je lui rentre là !
Ah mais non ça à coupé c'est le sketch !
Hé regardez là tout d'un coup j'ai un cancer et un sida !
Alors que j'ai pris juste une patate !
La fin de ce sketch est l'un de mes préférées de tout Golden Moustache.
Et les gens la trouvent super mignonne !
C'est ce qui fait les meilleurs fins de sketchs
C'est ceux où ça fait rire certains et ça touchent d'autres !
Pour l'anecdote, Anis bandait !
Regardez, regardez !
Elle cache avec son coude !
Là ces des sketchs sur la chaîne de Golden, vous avez votre propre chaîne maintenant.
Elle s'appelle Multiprise !
Le lancement !
Ça j'ai compris !
On a une chaîne qui s'appelle Multiprise.
Et en plus on peut le dire,
Parce que là quand la vidéo sortira normalement on est bon.
Y a la saison 2 qui viens de commencer.
On a déjà bien soulé les gens sur la chaîne de Golden Moustache.
D'ailleurs la suite c'est du porte à porte chez les gens pour dire "Abonnez vous".
En vrai, très bon concept de vidéo.
Là maintenant, c'est Jojo.
Donc mon deuxième sketch en tant qu'auteur et acteur pour youtube.
J'ai mis du temps à l'écrire.
Et Flober l'a réalisé.
Je l'ai laissé l'adapter car j'avais envie qu'il se l'approprie aussi.
Il y a plein de petits détails, si vous regardez les vidéos à droite,
C'est plein de clins d'oeils à des générations de ce qui se passait sur Youtube.
Et toi tu as rajouté plein de petites idées comme ça.
Ça on l'a tourné à la première Vidéo City Paris.
On a profité d'avoir une foule en délire, j'avais besoin d'avoir des vrais youtubeurs connus.
Donc Simon, qui est un vrai youtubeur qui cartonne vraiment,
Qui là pour l'occasion a fait Jacki l'Agrume
faut savoir que les T-shirt Jacki l'Agrume existent,
que j'ai voulu les faire gagner, mais je suis nul en orga...
Je sais plus qui a eu l'idée de mettre une vraie souris...
C'est moi !
C'est une très bonne idée, mais c'était très très dégueulasse
d'avoir les doigts dessus.
C'est le genre d'idée où tu les as, tu te dis génial !
et la souris c'est une souris morte !
Ah la Gladiance !
Avec des belles lunettes... Rasé !
En fait je fais plus vieux rasé !
On m'a dit rase toi pour faire plus jeune, mais finalement  j'ai pris 10 ans.
Chroniqueur web dans cet homme !
On va lancer une petite vidéo de chat !
C'est maintenant !
Ça d'ailleurs c'est une blague que t'as trouvé sur place
sur le fait que je te rende pas le téléphone
on se rendaient compte que ça fait très premier degré
et sur le tournage on se rendaient compte que ça faisait longtemps que y avait pas de blague,
Parce qu'en plus le pire c'est que à la lecture quand on étaient à la réunion d'auteurs.
ça nous faisaient rire ce texte.
On s'est rendu compte que dans la situations c'était vraiment moins drôle.
Y a Flober qui m'a bien dirigé, pour pas trop tomber dans le pathos.
Parce que c'est compliqué quand on compose un personnage comme ça.
On étaient en hiver, donc en hiver pour les gens qui savent pas,
les tournages, t'as beaucoup moins d'heure de tournage, car il fait nuit dès 16h30.
Je suis très fier de ce sketch et très content de l'avoir fait à Golden.
et on m'en parle souvent en dédicace et tout
C'est le truc qui reviens souvent, on me demande de signer mes petites tartelettes.
Ouais moi j'ai kiffé le faire aussi.
Ok, c'est moi je vais lancer.
Je suis fatigué en ce moment j'arrive pas à dormir.
Je suis désolé les gars je suis...
Toujours aussi nul.
On fait genre on sait pas qu'il va parler.
Je sais pas ce que j'ai en ce moment j'arrive pas à dormir !
C'est une insomnie ?
C'est fou ça !
Putain c'est pile le titre du sketch que l'on va regarder !
Oh mais regardons le alors !
Alors, l'Insomnie de Valentin Vincent !
C'était à l'époque où j'avais des cheveux.
Qui a coréalisé ce sketch avec toi ?
Stefan Carlod, on l'a réalisé à deux donc.
Avec le même doigt ?
Ok, c'est là où c'est violent, c'est là où...
Cette scène là, alors là c'est la dernière prise.
Y en a eu pas mal parce que...
J'étais extrêmement gêné pour des raisons évidentes.
Je connaissais pas si bien que ça Eléonore.
Et que le but c'était vraiment que...
Fallait vraiment que ça soit violent pour que le côté euh...
Même là si tu la connais mieux ça te gênerais pas de le refaire ?
C'est gênant quand même.
Et tu étais D.A la dessus.
Et comment tu as eu l'idée de ce sketch qui est sorti, je rapelle
avant la vidéo de Norman, "l'Insomnie".
J'ai eu cette idée parce que je dormais mal, tout simplement.
J'ai eu l'idée la nuit.
Ce qui m'énervait quand j'arrivais pas dormir c'est que
j'avais l'impression de me parler à moi même,
et que c'était moi qui m'énervais.
C'est ce que j'ai voulu montrer, je m'auto fait chier dans la vidéo,
Et les gens ont dit, ah ouais moi aussi !
Donc j'étais content d'avoir réussi ça.
Et qui joue le deuxième ?
Heath Ledger !
Et tu dors mieux maintenant ?
Oui je dors mieux merci.
Non mais je sais pas y avait un truc.
Très beau plan, et j'en suis très content, ce plan je l'aime beaucoup.
Enfin voilà donc je suis très content de ce sketch,
Très content de l'avoir fait avec Eléonore, avec vous tous.
Est ce que c'était une belle expérience humaine ?
Belle expérience humaine.
Ça valait le coup de pas dormir 10 ans.
Exactement !
"Le bureau des rêves"
Qui à maintenant quatre ans je crois, qui est très vieux.
Non j'étais content, car c'est l'un des sketchs les plus perso.
Y a plein de gens supers.
Y a Lucien et Adrien dans des petits rôles.
Mais y a aussi Simon Astier, David Salle, Julien Pestel,
La soeur de Justine Le Pottier.
Et ça devait être deux mes à la base
ça devait être Kyan Khojandi
à la place de Justine Le Pottier,
et ça n'a pas pu se faire pour plein de raisons.
Pour les cheveux principalement.
Simon joue très bien les connards,
J'ai beaucoup de mal à lui faire jouer autre chose qu'un pur débile.
Et Pestel joue un gros beauf qui parle que de cul
et ça aussi je l'adore dans ce registre.
Il y a un truc qui me plaisait aussi, mais c'est mon côté vieux tonton
Moi ça m'évoque vraiment les films noirs des années 50.
Non, la référence j'avais dit
imaginez le film "Good night and good luck" de George Clooney
aux couleurs de Brazil, j'ai dis ça au chef op.
Et la musique de fin est de Théo Bernard
qui est mon frère, voilà.
Et ça c'est une photo de moi petit avec mon papa.
Je savais pas.
Et c'est Vladimir Rodionov
qui était le directeur d'écriture à l'époque
et je le remercie car j'avais ce sketch
J'osais pas aller la dedans dans le deuil
Je voulais surtout parler du fait de pas trouver le sommeil.
Il m'a dit "Non, ose, faut y aller".
Et tant mieux sinon j'aurais pas pu faire la saison
Donc j'étais parti sur une rupture
Il m'a dit " Non non les ruptures on s'en bat les couilles"
J'adore ce plan !
Ouais moi aussi je suis très fier.
Et on diffuse un sketch du Golden Show, faut le savoir.
C'est le premier dans ta fibre comme "Le syndrome post-rupture".
Premier sketch chiant quoi.
C'est ça.
Simon, juste pour dire deux mots
c'est devenu un, c'est un coup de foudre.
C'est quelqu'un que je considère comme un ...
quelques un des grands frères de ce métier.
On a beaucoup travaillé ensemble, on se voit souvent.
C'était un vrai coup de foudre.
Et je l'ai sucé 5 fois.
Bon ben c'était cool
Ah c'était bien.
Ah c'était un bon moment !
A dans cinq ans !
Et surtout merci beaucoup les abonnés de Golden Moustache.
Merci beaucoup de regarder.
Non je faisais un cinq.
On fais genre on s'en va, on fait genre on part
alors qu'en fait on reste mais on fait genre on s'en va ?
Aller on fait genre on part.
Aurevoir, aurevoir, merci !
Ah les escaliers sont trop petits dans cet immeuble.
Décidément c'est trop petit.
On vous voit encore.
Tu sens bon.
Je te remercie.
FloBer !
Ouais ?
Allo ? Oui ? Studio Bagel ?